men are shockingly misrepresented in the
media and Academia and the way that
people presume that men are I think is a
million miles from it we take the
examples of the worst possible man the
worst possible behavior and we
generalize it to all men and then we go
around to school's warning boys to not
be that guy
why did you found these
psychology
there's a couple of reasons one is that
the general need for more accurate
information on men's psychology
um and the other was uh because we had
to already got a male psychology section
of the British psychological society
that was facing the professional uh
people dealing with psychology and men's
mental health but we also needed to have
something that was more public-facing
because I found over the years I've been
doing this for about 10 years to 12
years now and that there's actually a
lot more interest and awareness funnily
enough about men's psychology in the
general public than there is within the
Professional Psychology and I was quite
surprised when I started to understand
this but not only are people outside
psychology more interested in male
psychology or men's mental health but
there seem to have more insights than a
lot of people who are in Psychology I
say that and I feel a bit embarrassed
for for my profession why do you think
that is
uh well I think that there's a it's a
lot of it is the education in Alberta
commas that we get about gender
especially
um in Psychology part of it is that we
uh there's a bit of a blind spot in that
we don't really even focus on men as as
a topic of interest
at any level of psychology education uh
the one exception now is um the
University of Sunderland has got a
module an undergraduate module on male
psychology which gets brilliant feedback
but it's it's the one
um piece of of a a module in the world
that focuses on land psychology so we
have um on one side a blind spot to to
even looking in that direction but also
when we do look in that direction we
often have a kind of see it through a
particular lens that sort of distorts uh
what people see so we we tend to
um see men as as being really The
Architects of our own problems
um but there's there's
Fair bit of what you could call victim
blaming that happens so if men have
mental health problems and they fail to
seek therapy or any kind of help and
they don't speak to people because
they're too manly and stoical well as
their own fault kind of if if they end
up
um you know ending their own lives and
there's that kind of I mean I actually
on my undergraduates degree back in the
90s
um when we were discussing male suicide
which was a what was discussed in the
space about two minutes compared to to
talking about
um lots of other topics in mental health
including women's depression which we
just really went into quite some detail
when it came to explaining male suicide
and given that women are twice as likely
to have
um a severe depression than men are
um but man of three ties were like these
kind of suicide the women are
um but uh the explanation given was that
men are better at DIY so they just
construct better methods of getting rid
of themselves and uh in my seminar group
that got a little kind of Ripple of uh
laughter and I was kind of I was sitting
there thinking well
you know I'm not I'm I'm here to learn
um but I'm just I'm not really sure I'm
I'm learning anything very good here
there's no theory behind here it's
almost like we've just had a little bit
of stand up and outside afterwards um we
had a break and someone came up to you
and said I was a woman so uh you know
well done I don't know how you managed
to sit there through that and say
nothing and and uh I mean I just as I
said like you know and lots of students
are I think the same you know you're
there to learn you you absorb this
information you think it's a professor
telling me this it must be true and uh
you know so we we just don't get enough
accurate information about men's
psychology we hear especially when it
comes to medicine and vaccines and such
like that the male default that there is
a form which is used most drugs are
optimized for the men the male body most
vaccines are optimized for the male body
we have different immune responses so on
and so forth are you saying that this
male default or whatever hasn't been
ported across when it looks it comes to
studying psychology
oh yeah most definitely
um especially when it comes to therapy
then you you very much get a female
default but in terms of
um examining men at all no it doesn't
and in terms of medicine I mean I I
think it's
it's sometimes unfairly character
characterized as being well it's a man's
world so you know it's it's it's
medicine for man bye man type of thing
which is not really true I think that um
when it comes to
um testing experimental medication uh
it's a bit like being an experimental
pilot and experimental fighter plane or
something like that you know it's a
dangerous thing you don't know what's
going to happen there's some horror
stories like recently or well 10 years
ago there was um the what they call the
the guy who's I think they call them the
Elephant Man because his he took some
experimental drugs that was supposedly
okay but his his head kind of expanded
up to some very terrifying
um shape
um now men go in through lots of dirty
dangerous jobs and I think being the the
guinea pigs is one of them and there's a
good reason for that too I mean like uh
nobody I mean I think men tend to be
protective of women so so there's that
but there's a good reason I mean it's
very often a woman who's a child bearing
age doesn't necessarily know when she's
pregnant if she's taking a medication
that no one really knows what the
effects are that might damage the fetus
and we have no idea what the consequence
of that might be so there's very good
reasons why uh you know women should be
protected and their their unborn
children protected from that sort of
process why is there a difference in
Psychology studying the female brain
when medicine appears to be studying the
male form like what's the reason for it
being that way around
uh well I don't think we're studying the
female brain it's it's not so much a
biological thing it's it's a lot of bad
um behaviors more than brain I mean if
you're you're trying to go on a fishing
exposition to to find all the
differences between men and women in
their brain that that can be a really
subtle and controversial trip
um but what we're looking at more is the
way that for example in in terms of
therapy the ways men and women tend to
respond differently to to stressful
situations and that that's a really key
thing so we have the we've got the the
model that really applies quite well for
women so um when we think about somebody
who's depressed we think about somebody
who's maybe cries and kind of you know
they feel sad and down and and uh they
might want to talk to people about how
they're feeling
um and that applies more so to men than
women and of course we have to do the
caveat here of you know there's
different distributions of behaviors and
things and types and not all women are
the same and not all men are the same
but by and large
um I think it's important to recognize
that that what we do when we're dealing
with patients uh and in therapy tends to
to be more about what women like and
respond to than what men do and so women
do tend to fit into this and it could be
you know some people suggest it might go
back to say when Freud who his client
group uh were almost all women and uh
and that kind of model
um has sort of just become the default
from there I mean how true that is I
don't know but it's certainly one that
we have to this day is this what you
call the male gender bias
yeah this is
um this is part of male gender uh
blindness is is something that Martin
Seeger Consulting clinical psychologist
who who really started the male
psychology movement in in uh in the UK
um he coined this uh phrased male
genderblance which
tells you about
um just that this uh cognitive
um Distortion really that we have like
it's it's not something that people do
intentionally and people might be very
fond of of men in general but they tend
to have a sort of a blind spot to being
able to see when men are having problems
or even when boys are having problems we
see it much more readily when when it's
uh problems are happening to women and
girls than we do men or boys so and I
think this this is borne out quite a bit
actually and this is the the as a
psychologist obviously I'm interested in
in Psychology and and where male
blindness male gender blindness tends to
to be most obvious this is in the
therapy room
what beta bias and Gamma bias
right
um so
well I'll start with Alpha bias Alpha
biases is something it relates a bit to
what we were talking about with um
um Trials of um medicines
um it was has been said and it is still
said quite a lot that there's a bias in
favor of of looking at that stuff
um from a men's perspective and Alpha
bias in in research and psychology was
said to be
um the tendency to look for sex
differences in any research that you do
this this was a focus of interest and
and magnifying differences between men
and women under kind of male rats and
female rats that you know that was that
was a big thing and uh then beta bias is
um
uh the the opposite really it's
minimizing differences between men and
women and that's what we've got really
yeah and it's another way of expressing
male gender blindness is we have a
tendency to minimize any differences
that we see between men and women so
when we have a therapy and it works well
for women we don't really question
whether it might not work for men
because we're we're saying well there's
no real differences between men and
women and in fact you know the the
saying about this is there are more
similarities than differences between
men and women which is absolutely true
and absolutely true but then again you
could say that genetically there's more
similarities between men and or humans
and uh mice
um there are others like we shared 95 95
percent of genes
um but there are differences and those
differences make all the difference and
I think that's what gets missed with
this this I think in when he made many
ways a well-meaning uh view of of people
like this men and women are more or less
the same so we shouldn't treat them
differently and the fear is that if you
do treat men and women differently that
you're going to uh you know you're going
to lead people back to the days of
patriarchy and things ideas like this is
gonna it's gonna end up disadvantaging
women
um and I I just don't think that's true
at all and I I think that we've we've
come to the point when we have to
discuss things in terms of
um the fact that that men are committing
suicide three times the rate that women
are and and all sorts of other problems
that that suggest that men are having
unresolved mental health issues like man
um you know substance abuse it took
twice the level that women do and
homelessness much uh you know rough
sleeping much more the prison population
you know 95 where there's there's many
ways in which you you see that that men
are having issues that aren't being
dealt with
um by psychologists or therapists
they're going
um they're being overlooked and a lot of
this is
um male gender blindness in this beta
bias that we have and Gamma biases then
a kind of an elaboration of of the idea
of B device and again Martin Seeger
um is the person that identified gamma
bias
um
and this is the the tendency to uh for
example when uh when people do things
that are good
um sort of things that that uh you know
you would normally applaud and and uh
you know think that they might get prize
and things like that we tend to when it
it's uh done by a woman we tend to
emphasize the fact that this is a woman
achieving this award
um or doing this great thing but if a
man does it we tend to to to not um
emphasize his gender so much it's just
kind of like it kind of goes in the
background it's a woman though it's oh
look at this brilliant woman
um and this it becomes more of a serious
issue when it happens uh in terms of
um negative things like for example a
topical thing is violence when violence
is done by Men We tend to to emphasize
the fact that it's a man it's a violent
man but if violence
um is done by one we tend to play down
that like you know somebody got um
stabbed or something like that the fact
that it's a woman might kind of
disappear to the end of the story if it
appears to tell and that there's this
this is quite important I think
um in many different ways but because we
then I think as therapists and we uh one
one very important thing in therapy is
to have empathy for your client and if
we're uh if if we basically don't like a
client all that much because we're
presuming really negative things about
them I think that's very likely to
interfere with What's called the
Therapeutic Alliance and one of the the
things that makes makes the difference
between therapy being successful or not
out is Therapeutic Alliance it's it's
the thing that most consistently
explains the difference between therapy
the works out and therapy that fails and
if you have people who presume that they
if your client is is male they they've
got male privilege they might have had
an easy life much easier than women if
if they and if they say something and
this is not uncommon if if they're if
this my client says that the reason is
there is because he's depressed why
depressed well you know I you know I get
into fights with my wife well it's very
easy to presume these days that well you
know he's he's the guy who starts the
fight so or if she's hit and why what
did he do to deserve it you know what's
he done you know people fall into this
sort of mindset and uh I I think it's
really important that
um especially for therapists I mean if
if we're supposed to be trying to
understand people make them where
they're at and not trying uh kind of
impose the idea that they should be able
to talk about their feelings more than
they might want to uh you know for
therapists we should be able to to make
a much better
um uh you know day's work out of dealing
with men than I think that we do and I
think it's not surprising that men don't
turn up for therapy because lots of men
just they they understand this it's it's
fairly obvious to them
is that the gender empathy Gap is that
another way of describing it yeah
generally all of these these ideas are
kind of overlapping I mean that it's one
of these sorts of things where you've
had different people in different places
come up with a similar sort of idea and
and get that gets a slightly different
name but the gender empathy Gap is named
a very good book but also
um describes um this this kind of
condition that we we tend to sympathize
with with women when they have problems
more than we sympathize with men yeah I
mean
it's a difficult one because we want to
try and get to encourage men to open up
you want to try and give women the
opportunity to achieve parity in
education and employment and
Independence and financial achievement
and so on and so forth and it's
difficult to not have that done at the
cost of
um accusing males of of tyranny and
patriarchal oppression and stuff and I
saw you share something about the
guidelines from the APA and dangers of
traditional masculinity
yeah
um so that there's the one of the things
that's that's been quite controversial
in recent years is the the American
Psychological Association released uh
guidelines on uh doing therapy with boys
and men and uh a lot of people were very
pleased that these came out
um until they read them and then uh
there's I mean broadly speaking they're
quite good there's 10 guidelines in
there most of them are good guideline
number nine which is about how to do
therapy with men it's actually really
good I mean I I would stand by that but
there are a couple of guidelines there
um that really mess up the rest that the
whole of the guidelines um it's one of
these things where you know
um
oh okay so I'll describe them so
guideline one is um
about um it makes an assumption that
that masculinity is um is a social
construct which is a very popular idea
and it seems to make sense if you look
at the way men behave and dress around
the world that you know men behave and
dress and talk differently you know
um on the other hand there are some
commonalities there
um uh which tend to get overlooked I
mean so we're told that the reason man
uh or any differences between men around
the world are due to socialization
um so if you're uh you know if you're in
a country that tells men that they
should have long hair well then they
have long hair and because they're
socialized to have long hair and if it's
short hair a culture that tells no short
hair well you know people just fit into
those sorts of things but
there's um there's a lot of evidence I
mean and and it's very unpopular to
bring this up
um in social sciences these days mainly
because we've spent about the last 30 40
years
um you know talking about all the ways
in which um socialization of man has
been bad for men and bad for women
um but we Overlook um you know some
really obvious
um evidence very hard evidence actually
that um there's biological correlates to
to lots of things about uh men's
behavior so there's things about
masculinity that are hard to to get away
from the biological
um influence of so for example if we
take um
something like um uh the impact of
testosterone on fetal development
um this this completely a week 13 the
the Y chromosome triggers the release of
surge of testosterone and so the fetus
um will experience a similar levels of
testosterone to an adolescent boy so
high levels of testosterone and this
changes the the uh the the the foods and
tonics so they are programmed then for
the development of things like
um a different bone structure larger
muscle mass and and then I mean there's
other psychological things that that are
kind of more controversial but may well
be true like they may well be programmed
for
um a a better ability at a mental
rotation of things in other words a kind
of ability to to see things in
three-dimensional space of it but better
than women to
um certainly in adults there seems to be
um some differences there and some
studies the fan correlations with
testosterone and I found from a
conversation I had a couple of weeks ago
with David putz at the age of three
there is a 50 accuracy disparity in
throwing Precision at the age of three
yeah so if you get toddlers boys and
girls you split them into two groups and
get them to throw this isn't to do with
power this is before testosterone from
uh puberty's kicked in this is
exclusively due to that and it seems
like this predisposition toward mental
rotation now what women seem to be
better at was remembering the location
of things within a smaller area so this
would have made sense this would have
been adaptive right if you're a forager
and you need to know let's say you've
got a one kilometer radius around
wherever the current tribe is situated
and you need to remember where's the
good route where's the bad route where's
fresh water where's bad water where's
the bush that's got lots of berries
where the bus got less and it kind of
plays into the Trope like lots of
cliches are born out of genuine
biological predispositions it's why guys
always lose their keys but women can't
remember the directions to get to the
their office or whatever it's like when
you're talking about a broader range of
things a broader distance men appear to
have a better ability being able to
remember that but when you're looking in
a smaller area like around the house
perhaps they seem to be pretty useless
and the converse is true for women
interesting yeah I mean the throne thing
I mean there's the prenatal surgeon at
13 weeks that goes on for for several
weeks then there's a postnatal surge too
and boys again for another very high
surge of testosterone
um that happens
um in the months after they're born I
don't know how much that has an effect
on on throwing ability but there's loads
of these things that we think of as
being stereotypes and tropes uh that are
in fact true they're real I mean The
Stereotype comes about for a reason in
lots of cases and so like people I mean
I hate to say use the term you probably
didn't use throwing like a girl I mean
Danny but because instantly now loads of
people just turned off they've just
stopped watching the video
um but there's something to that I mean
you know and people shouldn't get worked
up or feel bad about it unless they want
men and women just to be exactly the
same for some reason yes I don't have
any problem with with just people
valuing differences completely totally
no problem also have no problem at all
with with everybody being allowed given
opportunities to to do whatever they can
do in their life so if they want to if a
Girl Wants to be a pitcher in the for
the New York Yankees or something like
that she should absolutely have every
opportunity to do that
what do you think about the term toxic
masculinity
uh obviously well not obviously okay
because a lot of people think that's
perfectly reasonable to use this term
um there is a some sense to it but I
think uh what's happened is a term that
was originally used
um by some um uh the methyl poetic um
type of guys back in the 80s and 90s
they started using this term to describe
young men who had not been initiated
into the tribe and if if for whatever
reason a young man was not didn't go
through the initiation ceremonies which
would help them to become a member of
the tribe
um they would kind of go off and kind of
go a bit wild they wouldn't kind of feel
any affiliation with the tribe there'd
be a nuisance and so this was called
toxic masculinity and you know there's
you know different suggestions of how to
to Reign them back in but basically they
were um
there was a it kind of made some sort of
sense however This this term has been
used out of context and it just becomes
like it gets thrown around in the media
um quite a bit
um and uh it just gets used in a generic
way to describe any behavior that men do
like you know so-called man spreading or
whatever it might be or even men staring
at women on the tube which is now
illegal in London
um you know staring at women on the tube
is illegal in London okay so we need to
dig into this John yeah if you um
actually it's one of the articles in the
male psychology magazine which is on the
the center for mail psychology website a
very good article uh written recently
um by Jenny Cummings Knight she's a
psychotherapist um over here in England
and uh she uh she's written a very good
piece lots of people have liked it um
it's it's pointing out the the the the
idiocy really of having a law an actual
law that can put men in prison for us
looking at women in a way that's
interpreted as being a sexual harassment
now this is a very subjective thing
obviously like it and and so Jenny
points out all the different ways in
which
um a man might be staring at a woman or
apparently staring at them he might he
might be blind actually somebody came up
with the with an example of of this
where a a blind guy was was in the gym
and he got he certainly found some woman
was was shouting in his face about to
stop staring at him and he's saying look
so I'm blind you know I'm not staring at
you see stop sorry if you don't stop and
she brought the manager over and he was
saying look I'm blind I'm not staring I
can't show them his card because and uh
has still he I you know people just
presumed that that's that he was doing
something bad because he was apparently
saying this one well in London on the
the London Underground another public
transport it is you can now go to jail
if you're a man and you do that a senior
police officer has urged everyone who
witnesses intense staring on the London
Underground to report it amid concerns
it could be an early sign of unhealthy
sexual Behavior posters of now being
placed in the tube train stations across
the capital stating intrusive staring of
a sexual nature is sexual harassment and
is not tolerated
yeah I mean the thing is I mean uh
there's so many ways in which you can go
wrong for example I mean I had someone
from Spain saying I actually Jenny wrote
about it in the article
um that that in Spain you can stare at
people it's not considered to be
threatening or or sexual harassment at
all people just just stare at each other
all the time it's just eye contact is
not a bad thing under London Underground
I mean of course
um you know probably probably the same
lots of confined spaces it it does feel
a bit more intense and intrusive is if
people look at each other especially if
they're looking in in writing directly
in somebody's face so I can understand
that people would feel uncomfortable
about it but uh in the current climate I
think that that of of
um I've really I think that there's a
lot of just you know this idea of toxic
masculinity
um all men get and this is one of the
problems with the term talks of
masculinity is is that it it's it sort
of tars all men with the same brush and
and although people say oh no we don't
mean old man we just mean the men who do
these things well when you use a term
like toxic masculinity it's when you you
tag toxic onto masculinity it inevitably
is just it poisons the whole
um the anybody who's possessing
masculinity gets poison which is man
basically well by Design it's a
catch-all term right it's a catch-all
term for any Behavior by a man that you
deem to find
distasteful or objectionable so Richard
Reeves was on the show a little while
ago and the school that his kids went to
in Washington DC there was a um an
incident that occurred where some of the
boys in class had created a ranking
system of all of the girls in class from
most attractive to least attractive and
that had been deemed as something that
was toxic masculinity you go I mean it's
distasteful but let's not forget that
that's literally the website that
Facebook was built off of the back of
like Facebook was that very website
incarnate and now it's one of the
biggest companies in the entire world
like is it toxic masculinity for boys to
re like if girls did it would that be
toxic femininity I don't think it would
be
um but yeah it's I I understand the
concept creep of wanting to
um create a label the desire to mimify
anything in the modern world and be able
to bring it under an umbrella because it
makes it sound more official it makes it
sound like something that's got
legitimate uh scientific rigorous
intellectual academic backing because
it's it's not it's just it's just a term
that you've decided to use to smear any
behavior from guys that you don't like
yeah and I mean I think one of the
problems with this is that we don't know
what the impact is on on boys growing up
of of uh hearing about these sorts of
labels and this General narrative for
bad men being bad or at least
potentially bad didn't you do you did a
new report about the factors that
predict well-being and 4 000 men and
that had some tie-ins with their views
of masculinity what did you learn from
that yeah um so this was on men rather
than boys I mean I I am more concerned
about the effect on boys because I think
it might be more have a more powerful
negative impact but this was on um uh uh
you know two thousand men in the UK 2000
men in Germany very similar results in
both countries and we found that or I
found that um
that some of the most significant
predictors of their mental well-being
were how they thought that masculinity
affected their behavior so that men who
thought that masculinity
um made them recycle less and be less
environmentally friendly this sounds
silly but
um men who a man who thought that that
masculinity made them inclined to be
more violent to women and made them less
inclined to talk about their feelings
um these men this this kind of uh set of
ideas was strongly correlated with them
being uh having a less positive mindset
and this when I say less positive
mindset this uh this this
um questionnaire that I used the
positive mindset index is is itself
strongly correlated inversely with them
suicidality so when you say somebody is
lower a lower positive mindset you're
saying that they're probably going to be
more suicidal in their thing thinking so
basically men who think that masculinity
has a bad effect on their behavior are
you know have worse mental health you
could say in a nutshell and we found the
converse was true
um but only in the German sample
significantly
um
that men who thought that masculinity
was good for their behavior so made them
more protective of women made them
um want to be better
um dads and you know better providers in
their home these men had better Mental
Health
um so I I think you know I've there's
probably although we're talking about a
correlational design here there is some
reasonably good Smoking Gun evidence
that's that's
having being exposed to a neg to a
negative um narrative about masculinity
and and internalizing that then and
thinking that masculinity is a bad thing
is going to make you feel worse why
wouldn't that be the case you know
you're kind of born it's like it's
basically the same as original sin it's
the same concept as original sin you
know you're born as this Fallen creature
there is something innate and in you
that is a part of you that you didn't
choose but is also somehow toxic or
damaged or insufficient
yeah I mean at least with the original
sin there's Redemption you know you can
I mean I guess certain therapists might
think that they can redeem you but I'm
not sure I just I I'm very worried about
the impact on boys
um a lot of people are too we did a
survey a couple of years ago
um that found that I think 80 to 85 of
people thought that that were concerned
that that's the narrative around toxic
masculinity would have a negative impact
on boys we really like getting back to
psychology as a profession we need to be
more interested in this we're not even a
little bit interested in this this is
this is one of the terrible things we're
interested in finding out all the ways
in which masculinity is bad for men and
bad for for society we're not interested
in in really examining that idea and
seeing whether this idea of toxic
masculinity or hegemonic masculinity any
of these ideas are are really just uh
social constructs that psychologists and
sociologists have come up with that we
impose on people's behavior and then all
we see is evidence that confirms
um our preconception about them being
bad and and uh and having this masculine
original sin uh we we really need to be
more like scientists and and investigate
these things challenge hypotheses and
look outside our usual uh what's called
a kind of narrow
um Paradigm fixation which has been used
to describe the way that a lot of
research in masculinity has been for the
last 30 odd years you also found
personal growth age and health
satisfaction as some of the other most
important factors that impacted the
well-being of men in that sample just
what's what's that as a high level what
are those things uh well so personal
growth is
um just an interest in your your own
personal developments was the strongest
predicamental men's mental well-being
um oh that seems I mean I know that
is that kind of like being your own
doctor in a way is that that you're
taking a greater appreciation for the
fact that you should be improving you're
more of a self-assessor when it comes to
what are the areas of my psychology my
health my relationships that are
insufficient and that I need to work on
yeah basically yeah so it's kind of I
mean I'm overlooking this I mean there's
lots of things in this report that
suggest that the man or anything but
toxic like the thing that makes men
happiest is when they're satisfied with
their own personal development
um another thing
um we did in that survey was ask man uh
what core values they thought was were
most important
um so the core values are being
adventurous and being
um athletic were at the bottom of the
list of things that they thought were
most important the things I was thought
were most important were being honest
reliable dependable and this was the
same across uh UK and Germany we'd asked
men previously in the states five
thousand in the states exactly the same
result I mean this is talk about curing
the replication crisis exactly the same
results and again when we asked 2009 the
UK in 2017 the same results these are
these are the things men are not men you
know they're desperately trying to to be
the best that they could be which was
actually funnily enough a tagline for a
Gillette ad back in the day but the best
that a man can get
um but um you know it's I it's um I
think men are shockingly misrepresented
in in the media and Academia and the the
the way that people presumed that Manara
thinks a million miles from we take the
the examples of the worst possible man
the worst possible behavior and we
generalize it uh to all men and and then
we go around to schools warning boys to
not be that guy
and not realizing that these sorts of
campaigns they're very easily backfire
that like the the psychology is full of
these unintended consequences you you
take this uh what I would say is
half-baked idea an idea that's not
properly researched you you've got the
best of intentions everyone says hooray
it sounds like a great idea let's go out
there and do it you do it and actually
you find that
um so in the in um
student populations in the states
they've tried these these sorts of
things where you
um like don't be that guy don't be the
guy goes around sort of harassing women
and being nasty and what they found is
that
um overall it seems to work yeah overall
on average it seems to work but actually
if you look down drill down into the
daily a bit a bit you find that the guys
who already were the nice guys are are
just as nice as they were before maybe a
bit nicer
the guys who who weren't impressed with
any of the stuff in the first place have
now got worse so you've just made the
problem worse you've just you've got you
you maybe how would it be the case that
you would get good outcomes from this
kind of a campaign if the good guys got
better and the bad guys got worse if the
good guys weren't going to do anything
in any case how do you get better
outcomes because 95 of of the the people
in that study are good guys so when they
all improve these guys kind of get worse
it's it's these the bad guys get kind of
um uh you know they disappear in the
data because on average everybody is
improved today I mean this was the
Insight from David buss's Men Behaving
Badly right that was one of the the big
insights from that which is that almost
all sexual assaults that are conducted
by men perpetrated by men are done by a
very small number that are repeat
offenders you know you have a small
number of guys that are complete
[ __ ] and then you have this big
wealth of of guys that that behave in a
perfectly acceptable manner toward women
and the problem is that when you do take
this broad Strokes brush you end up
causing most men most of whom are well
behaving to feel
fearful ashamed guilty disgusted
whatever about their own masculinity I
remember I was reading an article that
you shared a little while ago and this I
think was in Ian Brower College in
Australia parents and male students were
left mortified after the school forced
them to stand in assembly and apologize
to their female classmates for sexual
assaults committed by males Broward
College in southwest and Victorian town
of
[Music]
I'm not even gonna try and say that
properly uh held an assembly on
Wednesday where boys were told to stand
up in a symbolic gesture of apology to
girls and women my 12 year old has no
idea about rape and sexual assault and
he was made to apologize and he doesn't
understand why earlier twelve-year-old
Levi who had only been at the college
since the start of the Year said he was
forced to apologize to many of his
classmates who he hadn't even met they
told us to stand up and turn to a girl
in our class and say sorry Levi told
current affair I don't think it's okay
to be sexually assaulted I felt a bit
under pressure to stand up and if I
didn't feel like I was a bad person
another student named Vinnie said that
there were several girls in the Assembly
Hall that began crying because they'd
been revealed in front of everyone as
having been victims I had Girls behind
me crying because they'd basically been
exposed to the entire school and we had
to apologize for stuff we didn't
actually do
what a mess I mean what an absolute mess
and this behind it I mean so uh that the
mayor of London is rolling out workshops
to to sort of help boys be better people
around women and be less sex and
everything like that I mean I don't know
what's in these workshops but if it's
anything like what you just described
who's it gonna help I mean who's going
to benefit from any of that
nobody it's public struggle session
exactly and uh you know the worst thing
is that of course the the guys who were
already going in that direction they've
just you've just Justified them being
you know as bad as they want to be they
just they they hate the whole world I
mean you see this I I
you know this is an N of one but I see
this online on the internet the guys
that spend the most amount of time
learning about gender Dynamics are the
ones that want to push back hardest
against this sort of
um whatever you want to call it like
hyper egalitarian or hyper sort of
um uh equal uh view of the world because
they do they feel like they're being
preached to they feel like they're being
told how to behave and if in that cohort
of people you have some people that were
already some men that were already going
to be [ __ ] they're going to feel I
don't know like
um virtuous backlash or or that you're
going to have that that sort of rebound
effect so to speak well when did this
negative view of masculinity start in
Psychology has it always been there no
not at all um it's I mean it used to be
like as I said man I haven't really
appeared very much in Psychology uh over
the years until around the 80s and 90s
and then uh from uh sociology really
um came this idea of hegemonic
masculinity and started up in the 70s
reached
um uh psychology around the the 80s and
90s and hegemonic masculinity kind of
caste man has been uh very competitive
very aggressive
um kind of domineering uh or you know
misogynistic uh homophobic and um and
this was adopted in by some people in
the states uh and and we developed them
you know it just snowballed from there
so men went from being considered as
being athletic and energetic and and
domineering and and aggressive uh you
know physically aggressive two being
then all these things like they became
homophobic and and Sexes and things and
so we we have definitions of masculinity
that are used in Psychology now not not
everyone's psychology uses because it's
still sort of a it's not a mainstream
part of psychology at the media has
picked up on a lot more
um governments have picked up and
unfortunately that you know including
the UN
um and Associated organizations like the
world health health organizations they
they tend to have adopted this negative
uh view of manner because the media have
run with that people like it's it's just
a general thing it's kind of part of our
atmosphere that we we tend to think of
that there's something wrong with men
you know that there's there at the very
least privilege if they've if they've
got wealth they haven't really earned it
you know they've they've had a kind of a
you know Head Start of over women I mean
it's it's it's a recipe for just
poisoning
um people against each other which I
think is awful and another bad thing is
that that of course it's for these guys
who do engage in these horrible sexual
your behaviors and bad behaviors
it doesn't solve that problem by just
saying that that it's caused by
masculinity you're not going to solve
the problem by by saying it's
masculinity you'll only solve the
problem
um by actually getting to the roots of
the problem and the roots of the problem
are usually for people like this
um uh early trauma trial childhood
trauma
um sometimes sexual trauma like for sex
offenders sexual trauma and there has
been some research by uh Naomi Murphy
who was a a clinical psychologist worked
with prison populations with some very
serious offenders
um that some of the the very worst sex
offenders
um they did have uh as their their the
kind of the background to the refunding
being sexually abused by and female
adults when they were children so you
have this so but who wants to look at
that I mean you know we're so far away
from being able to to deal with that
reality uh we'd much rather and and I
guess if you're a politician how you
know how are you going to change
somebody's childhood like that is so
difficult and the therapy takes an awful
long time
um but how are you going to change the
circumstances which could involve social
deprivation
um what Warren faralka's dad deprivation
like lacking a father figure to steer
people so that they're they they kind of
you know that they're socialized more
easily what's the um what are the in the
outcomes of fatherlessness because
obviously you know I can hear all of the
wives tales and and sort of myths that I
want but what what are the kind of
outcome changes that you get for boys
when they grow up in a fatherless home
and again so we have to start off saying
not everyone is affected in the same way
everyone's different some people might
Thrive from that and and lots of people
will have very good experiences with you
know positive
um
you know role models who are women and
in their lives um but if there's there
certainly seems to be evidence that if
we don't have some sort of like
not having a father actually the
research is interesting because they
never make a distinction between
um fathers and stepfathers doing father
figures but if you if you don't have a a
useful sort of Father Figure of absent
father absent families basically have
more likelihood of having
um delinquency yeah so and this this
applies to women to some extent too but
certainly for for men it can it can be
something that you
um people drift into a life of crime
well some it's often not a life of
crimes you're often a a decade of crime
or you know up until their 20s before
they grow out of it and start learning
to control themselves a bit more but um
yeah the the risk I mean there's plenty
of evidence that the risk of of boys and
families that don't have dads um are
more likely to drift into to delinquency
and loads of them don't
um
um but unfortunately it's true I mean
like you know it's again when people
talk about smash the patriarchy
um you know you have to kind of wonder
what they're talking about smashing
because there's I mean the patriarchy if
it exists uh in the UK or the states or
Australia Canada these days is the worst
most useless organization ever because I
mean I'm not sure what the the
advantages are that men have these days
so like with boys seem to be failing in
education a terrifying rights I mean men
are kind of um you know drifting uh you
know into homelessness um you know into
into prisons that at an alarming rate a
suicide levels drinking themselves to
death you know the the patriarchy
doesn't seem to have done very much uh
good for anybody so when you're talking
about smashing the patriarchy uh you
know who is the target I mean I I know
that people are saying smash that their
dad and your family but I think that
that's that's the only patriarch that's
really left and and I think a lot of
dads I mean they get depicted in the
media as being you know silly or
pointless and things like that I think
that there's just so much that's that's
kind of uh again as I say I worry about
children growing up
um you know with dads or without dads in
a culture that that really is so happy
to to mean anything to do with men what
challenges are particularly unique to
men when it comes to managing Mental
Health
ah I don't know if there anything would
be particularly unique
um but I I but there's there's um
barriers that that men have to overcome
a bit more than women so I think a lot
of men already they they
um we've done some research on this and
it's borne out by others people's
research too men when they got
um mental health issues or they feel
distressed
um they the first thing that they want
to do is is not necessarily talk to
somebody about how they feel about it in
fact they might not really feel very
much like doing that they want to fix
the problem so if it's
um that they're depressed because they
haven't got work they'll want to find
money somehow or other you know they'll
want to fix the problem they want to fix
their depression about not having work
they wanted to go out and get money
somehow or other
um and whereas women and we're back to
our kind of uh the the way that the
therapy um our our style of therapy
that's an offer for people these days is
more suited to women because in general
when women are distressed they'll want
to talk about their feelings they'll
they'll want to do that
um and and I will help them and actually
men can be helped a great deal by
talking about their feelings too but uh
it's not the first thing that they want
to do and and when they look around for
for somebody to talk to
you know you know it's not hard for them
to to to to realize that it's them you
know they can't just talk to anybody for
example getting back to to
um a male victim of domestic violence
and about a third of of victims of
domestic violence are men
um who is he gonna talk to about this I
mean a lot of of therapists unless they
they have knowledge or experience of
this might presume that if he's involved
in domestic violence that he started it
uh you know that he's the problem and of
course the police traditionally
are very similar actually this is
starting to change thanks to to people
like Mark Brooks and the mankind
initiative and uh and other people who
are uh you know spreading better
information like you know Mark Brooks is
very good at getting
um onto the television and telling
people about the facts about domestic
violence and um
so if a man is suffering from the
massive arms he knows that he can go to
the mankind initiative and you can fund
that hope their helpline and he knows
that he's not going to be presumed to be
an offender he knows that when he talks
to somebody there they will they will
accept that that that's he he may you
know they will not presume that he's uh
doing anything other than telling the
truth about his experience
um but a lot of of other places that man
can go they can't necessarily make that
assumption and lots of men know this I
mean like I have to say I mean I'm a bit
embarrassed uh I I have tended over the
years to to end up doing research on
things that actually most of the general
public already knew about so when I did
my research finding that that
um when when distressed women want to
talk about their feelings and men want
to fix the problem no one was surprised
except psychologists who I talked to
[Laughter]
um there's so many other things I mean
but uh it's strange isn't it strange
that you're having to reverse engineer
an ideology out of the discipline which
is supposed to know what the public is
already aware of
I I I again it's it's uh you know it's
terrifying in one way I mean we're
supposed to be the ones who kind of know
aren't we really you know yeah you're
supposed to be the tip of the tip of the
spear and downstream from that is the
general public that are learning off the
back of I mean yeah I
it's it's a it's a strange one I I
suppose especially when we're talking
about men getting into therapy I had
this guy Adam Lane Smith on the show
psychotherapist from the Midwest
and he was he really sort of red pilled
me about this about saying look men want
to be able to fix the problem men want
to be able to feel capable and in
control and you want to give them the uh
path out of it now women are happy to
talk about the
um their emotions but that doesn't
really make men feel any more capable
you know it might make them it help them
to open up and understand what's going
on but it doesn't fix the fundamental
sort of listlessness vulnerability that
is
um I guess a cause of a lot of Shame and
around this you see
I know like if uh if a guy is to open up
about something that he's struggling
with I'm a man who is going through a
difficult breakup let's say uh is sort
of told that they should get on with
things a woman that's going through a
difficult breakup is deserving of
sympathy now that's not to say that
again on average blah blah blah but
it doesn't seem to help the situation it
doesn't seem to help the situation
massively no it doesn't and it's I mean
again like when you mentioned the red
pill Community I mean there's all sorts
of of places online that that are kind
of you know that they're ahead of of
psychologists in this that they know it
and and guys know it like they will
gravitate to these places and they might
not always get the best help that they
need you know from these places I mean
that so what we need we need some sort
of combination of what a psychologist
can offer in terms of of the years of
because psychologists are usually very
good at dealing with a lot of issues I
have to say just when it comes to to man
these days it's it's it's not worked out
so well but they do need to to to be
um
to be more open to uh to to what they're
hearing from the internet not dismissing
it as being the manosphere and things
like that but the problem the problem
that you have if you don't have a an
authority which is not necessarily
regulated but is more rigorous with its
methods and stuff if you don't have that
available for men to go to they will go
to Reddit communities and Discord
servers and YouTube channels and stuff
like that and that's great up until the
point of which audience capture and the
incentives of audience capture encourage
those creators to make ever more
outlandish claims that can become toxic
in their own right there are 100
incredibly toxic negative areas of the
red pill manosphere black pill in cell
Community online that are the world
would be better if they didn't exist
right now the problem is and it's the
same reason as to why
um when people ask about how come the
right appears to have captured most of
the conversations around around men it's
like well because the left doesn't care
the left isn't having a conversation
with men about what it means to be a man
they're not presenting any positive role
models for either men to grow up into or
for masculinity as a concept generally
so you've just left this world open and
it's the exact same Dynamic that I'm
seeing with regards to psychology and
the manosphere as if you want to call it
as like one just big group psychology
and psychologists haven't spoken to men
in a way that gives them a firm footing
for them to stand on that helps them to
understand their own programming their
own nature so I'm going to go somewhere
I go to this place on the internet but
then we have a lot more uh perverse and
Contra incentives that are going to
cause those people to take information
and run play liberties with what it is
that they can say they're not beholden
to you know any rigors of Academia or
anything there's no regulations at all
and that is how you end up with this
sort of intensity spiral that creates an
Ever more
um aggressive and sometimes negative
community
yeah absolutely and psychology has
failed there I mean we we should have
never adopted this negative view
masculinity
um we should have been always more open
to what men need when they've got mental
health issues
for some reason we've just I mean as
Martin Seeker described it male gender
blindness we've just not been able to
see it uh we still
even though we have a male psychology
section that the British psychological
society and it's out there and it's it's
um you know it's it's giving the right
messages I mean who's listening I mean I
I just really really wish that more
people within psychology would pay
attention and and be open I mean
unfortunately you know there's a lot of
people who will just as soon as you
mention helping men they switch off that
they think that that's uh you know it's
like
um you're certainly gonna go back to
caveman days when men dragged women
around by the hair or whatever cavemen
supposedly did but it's not about that
is it if if you leave men who are
mentally unwell to their own devices
they're gonna be not very productive
members of the community to say the
least if you know so the cure for toxic
masculinity if you want to call it that
is to to actually listen to these guys
to help these guys to be open to these
guys to understand what the cause of
their problems is and not be afraid to
do that I mean because it's a big
challenge a big challenge like your
peers might reject you for wanting to
help man but also it's a big challenge
um like when you're face to face with
with some guy who's angry who's who's
heard he might want to hurt you he might
reject you entirely that's a big
challenge like forensic psychology is
one of the the the biggest challenges
that anyone can get involved with I have
huge respect for people who are working
in these areas uh but we really need to
to to to get real be realistic that not
fall for for the the the narrative and
the ideology that we've been fobbed off
with for too long how worried are you on
this Rise of sexlessness and loneliness
uh a lonely single man
yeah uh it's not gonna go anywhere good
I mean so
um a couple of the previous uh reports
that I've done I've looked at
um have found that that men who are in
stable relationships are like that much
happier than men who are single okay so
so this is this is borne out by lots of
different studies so being in a stable
relationship makes you happier whether
that's marriage or just being uh going
steady over a period of time but uh so
being single I mean it gives you some
opportunities for dating but I mean
actually most guys don't do that well on
dating apps and things like that it can
be pretty tough
um so what you turn to I mean that
there's porn and stuff like that I mean
and lots of men turn to porn when
they're distressed we've done some
research on on this too it's a kind of a
way of dealing way of coping like we'll
intend to to comfort eat more and men
tend to go to for porn more to relieve
stress and um no it's not going to go
anywhere good I mean it's it's
I'm you know we as a society are stupid
to think that this isn't something that
we should be paying more attention to
and not in a punitive way but to
actually just help these guys a little
bit and I'd say one of the first things
we could do is is recognize that a lot
of the messages that we're
um sending to men through are you know
through things like laws like about men
staring at women on the London transport
or things like talking about toxic
masculinity or headlines like why it's
okay to hate men or on the Internet this
idea of like kill old men like this but
you know kind of uh a phrase that that's
flies around I mean it's ridiculous to
think that this is not going to have a
bad effect uh on man and it's also naive
to think that this is not going to
rebound on all of us at some point well
it'll rebound on women as well because
fundamentally women require a partner
who is
worthy of them you know women 50.1 of
women for the first time in history are
childless by 30 a report that came out
by Reuters a couple of months ago said
that for the first time ever 45 of prime
working aged women between the ages of
22 and 45 will be single and childless
by 2030. all of these stats suggest that
women are struggling to find a mate that
they can contend with and are Attract it
to and I went out uh maybe a year and a
half ago with a friend and we were in a
bar in in London uh and he's single and
I sort of nudged him and pointed to a
group of girls over the far side near
the bar and I was like what what why
don't you go over and and talk to one of
those and he looked like I'd suggested
that we go and dismember one of them
he's like I've been told that I should
never approach a woman in a bar that
that that's that's incredibly dangerous
for me to do and he's gen Z so he's what
maybe 12 years younger than I am uh and
for me coming from the background that I
had which is like the back end of Laut
era Like Larry British lad culture in
sort of 2006 2010
um that that would be just unheard of
right there's no absolutely no concern
because he didn't have this panopticon
of Technology constantly surveilling you
you know uh but then on the other side
of this I can see why you could say
um that era that I was in where men were
going up to women would have meant that
women would had more approaches from men
that they had more opportunities to find
a good mate you know evidence seems to
suggest that women want to be approached
by men but then you also get negative
externalities you know a woman that says
no that rebuffs a man one times in X
many hundreds or thousand is going to
end up in a situation that she feels
very uncomfortable and then you have the
metoo uh Renaissance that was absolutely
needed but then what happens when you
overshoot and it's this it's this very
um
a black and white sort of uh
mono view of the world that it
everything is good or everything is bad
it's significantly easier to see people
in those regards one of the things I
wanted to actually mention that I've
come to realize or believe over this
year that was kind of interesting is um
there's often stories about how
when you have
societies with a high preponderance of
single men Men Without Partners that
that is just before some huge
instability that causes its downfall
right and there's some evidence
throughout history that seems to suggest
men get into relationship testosterone
drops men have a child testosterone
drops again they are part of a community
blah blah blah they're domesticated
essentially by their partner and their
family
um
one of the questions that I was toying
with for the back end of this year is
where are all of the in-cell killings if
it is the case that we have the highest
rates of sexlessness amongst men aged 18
to 30 ever in history why aren't there
roving bands of miscreants outside
pushing over granny and spray painting
stuff and causing havoc and I've come to
believe that what's happening is that
rather than those men going out with a
bang they're going out with a whimper
they are being sedated through porn and
video games into retreating away from
that state of seeking behavior that may
have got them a little bit of attention
which ultimately could have led them to
get a partner or or raise up in their
standing within the community
um and I I don't think
you know whatever five years ago or so
some of the concerns the Elliott Rogers
of the world you know we're going to see
this happening more and more and more we
just haven't you know it is it is not
going up in line with the uh the rates
of sexlessness and singleness amongst
men so you have to presume that
something else is happening in order to
be able to sedate men out of that
behavior and I think that it is this
porn and video games thing now if you
were to give me two worlds one in which
you have constant mass shootings done by
disaffected guys and another image that
doesn't happen like I'll take the one
that it doesn't happen but that you
can't say that the uh number of men
playing Call of Duty and smoking weed is
in any way also like useful that's
that's that's still not good it's just
less less bad than them taking the gun
from the video game into the real world
yeah as I said it's not going to end up
well for anybody you love these guys who
love unfulfilled lives
um people who would have been their
Partners will have unfavorville lies um
I have worked in uh in the field of
women's mental health too and uh one of
the things that that I saw a lot of was
um how distressing it is for for women
men also but how distressing it is for
women to have problems with their with
um conceiving a child I mean like the
amount of money gets spent on IVF and
how much stress that they will go
through is unbelievable and it's I mean
it's hard to appreciate when you're
younger how how much stress you're gonna
have when you get older because it's I
mean again we're back to tropes and
stereotypes but like this it's the idea
of the biological clock for women is I
mean in my experience of of dealing with
women in these situations it's it's true
and it's a tragedy and we we should we
should be trying to help everybody I
think to um to I mean in an Ideal World
you know we would have people kind of uh
meeting up in a kind of an effortless
way
um and and kind of matching off with
each other and having happy lives and
happy families I I think that would be a
good result for everyone but we're I
think we're we're scaring women away
from from men these days and and men are
just sort of feeling rejected and
backing into a corner and and that's not
good no and I wonder whether a world in
which most of your experiences of the
real world can be mediated by social
media and news you actually end up
experiencing experiencing many other
lives right the stories that you hear
about other people's lives as opposed to
your own and if we've got a world in
which remote work and more social
isolation comes through what you
actually end up doing is getting your
model of the world especially
relationships between the Sexes and you
take that from news but news isn't a
representative sample of the things that
are happening by Design the news
articles that come out are the ones that
are the most egregious it's the the
woman that divorces the man and takes
his brother and leaves him for dead and
all of his money's gone and she's taking
the dog and the dog won't even see him
again oh the the reverse you know a
woman says no to a guy in a the copy
room at work and she ends up being
chopped up and put in the freezer and he
eats her for chili and stuff like those
are the sorts of stories that you hear
and if you have fewer and fewer
interactions in the real world that can
disprove that what you end up with well
you end up with that being your model of
the world which feeds into the anxiety
which makes you less social which means
that you've got less Real World
experience to disprove the stories and
the cycle just continues yeah I mean in
a way everyone needs to get out more you
you could say and talk to each other
more too like there's some some really
good things happening like uh in terms
of men's mental health men's sheds a
really good idea just getting men
together puddle around do XYZ activity
it doesn't really matter what it is and
they get to just chat a little bit and
that's brilliant for their mental health
and there's sort of Andy's man club and
things like that where men get together
and these things you know kind of
getting outside being out the real world
finding out the reality is not as bad as
it is and the same for women too like
men are really not as bad as you might
think there's loads of brilliant guys
out there they might be stuck on their
Xbox at the moment but you know just
dust them off a little bit brilliant
look Dr John I really appreciate you
um where should people go if they want
to check out the stuff that you do
online
um best place is probably the center for
male psychology
um.com
um and uh we've got they can sign up to
our newsletter which is free and they'll
get the monthly magazine and which
you've talked about a couple of the the
articles in there yeah we get they're
very popular very good
um if you're a psychologist go to the
the male psychology section website on
the British psychological society and
you'll find that there's some oh there's
Central male psychology to a great place
we've got loads of Articles and academic
articles too as well as sort of more
General magazine articles so um and we
have questionnaires that you can use
like the positive mindset index and
things like that so yeah go go to those
places all right John thank you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]